Fabio Anya beanie always enjoys working
with wood particularly if it has a nice
texture what she made they get Lavina
the wood is smooth and even that's just
the right kind for making musical
instruments
she was really shown us but a major
windstorm on October 29th knocked down
almost all of the trees here involved a
p.m. local mythology the next day I felt
like a friend had died Mankato nameko
[Music]
the high winds blew down trees across
entire mountainsides totally could be
shaky sort of homothety Fucci doubt that
it sounded like gunshots or small
explosions when the wind knocks down an
entire tree it makes an awful lot of
noise it's like the sound of a million
branches breaking Fabio has been coming
to this area for 13 years to find just
the right kind of wood for centuries the
forest has provided wood for violins
guitars and pianos the wood gives the
instruments an excellent sound and
resonance but now Fabio is trying to
save what he can
jibanyan we stole this trunk is a good
diameter and a good texture but this
crack here shows that the tree split
when it was knocked over so I can't use
it
Fabio wants to save as much wood as he
can before it's ruined by bark beetles
and other pests water will mean to
thetable I love this kind of work and I
love these trees this is my passion
dan took about 34 minutes
the wood is processed at Fabio small
factory down in the valley this is where
Mountain spruce is converted into tone
wood and resonance wood Fabio's
customers include a number of major
companies that produce musical
instruments this finely cut tone wood
will be used to make violins it's been
sorted by age and quality more than 300
years ago
Antonio Stradivari crafted his violins
from wood similar to this
but right now Fabio is trying to recover
as much wood as he normally does in four
years and it's going to cost a lot of
money to store it so he's asked
customers and private clients to pay 300
euros in advance per tree trunk to cover
storage costs
that's why he's choosing only the best
wood right now the ESCO job I've got to
examine every trunk carefully to
determine which piece of wood would be
best for each instrument and how many
pieces I can get out of a trunk imagine
Armie the quarry for Sione Vienna for
tea only top quality wood will be
processed fabio keeps a close watch on
all of the tree trunks even in the
sawmill here the trunks are pre-cut
along the grain this wood will be used
to make sound boards for pianos sawmill
owner Franco saber is sorry that so many
trees were lost in the windstorm it took
those trees 120 years to grow to
maturity and then the storm ruined
everything it's sad and now it will take
another 120 years for the forest to grow
back
customers who appreciate Fabio skill and
experience will support him during these
tough times the favio has an extremely
important job he's the only one who can
find this kind of high quality wood
violin makers like me couldn't do it
but we're all part of the process of
creating a musical instrument so we have
to trust each other every step of that
process must be spot-on as Fabio stone
wood is made into a violin I'm happy
when the client is pleased with the
instrument the manufacturers and the
musicians deserve a lot of credit too
but people seem to forget that it's my
wood that makes the instrument Fabio on
eBay knees customers certainly haven't
forgotten and for the time being
he'll continue to salvage as much wood
as he can from the Valle de Fiamma site
so that he can keep providing
top-quality material for world-class
musical instruments
[Music]